the son of a factory worker princeton
history professor stephen cotkin has one
of the most fascinating minds i've ever
encountered
five questions for stephen cotkin on
uncommon knowledge now
[Music]
welcome to uncommon knowledge i'm peter
robinson
a professor of history at princeton and
a fellow at the hoover institution here
at stanford
stephen cotkin grew up in new york city
received his undergraduate degree from
the university of rochester and his
doctorate from the university of
california at berkeley he's the author
of nine works of history nine big works
of history including the first two
volumes of his biography of joseph
stalin
paradoxes of power 1878 to 1928 and
waiting for hitler
1929-1941
dr cotkin is currently completing the
third and final volume of that biography
of joseph stalin stalin totalitarian
superpower 1941 to 1990s and that will
be published in about two years
we hope we hope all right
kovid has prevented us from seeing each
other for the last couple of years
but i've been making notes
five questions for my friend stephen
cotkin
question one
china
you and i had a conversation
three four years ago in which it
occurred to me that you have probably
spent more time reading soviet archives
than any other person
and i said to you stephen what's the one
central finding
and you replied immediately they were
communists
the leaders of the soviet union really
believed that stuff and they really
wanted to achieve
the communist goal of
worldwide revolution
what does president xi jinping of china
believe and what does he
want
i'm thrilled to be back peter
i missed your show
and i'm sorry that we've had this hiatus
of a couple of years but it's really
great to be here today thank you for the
invitation thank you
of course i've been watching all your
shows in the interim
but it's really great to be back live
thank you stephen
so xi jinping like me
is a student of the soviet collapse
he spent a great deal of his time and
resources figuring out why that happened
in the soviet union and why it would
never happen in china
and they teach it at the communist party
schools the chinese communist party
schools he talks about it in public very
frequently
and it's uppermost in their minds
why
and the reason is just as the arguments
that i made in armageddon averted and
other volumes
communism is an all or nothing
proposition
you can't be half communist
either you have a monopoly on power
or
you don't
and so when you attempt to reform
communism politically
you can open up the economy as they do
sometimes with quasi markets right but
when you liberalize politically
and you allow discussion within the one
party within the communist party it
turns out that people want to have
discussions about other parties and
maybe they want to establish other
parties and so you can't contain
the liberalization within the one-party
monopoly
in fact when they did this in hungary in
1956 under imranaj
the whole thing unraveled
really in days
the prague spring
in 1968 and of course gorbachev in the
soviet union every time
they've attempted to open the system up
to get some quote democracy or
liberalization within the one-party
monopoly they've discovered that people
want other parties and people don't want
to stay within the communist monopoly
and so there's no reform equilibrium
there's no spot where you begin
political reform
and you're stable you stabilize it at
some point there's only
complete unraveling so you pull a thread
in the sweater
and that one thread and the entire
sweater unravels
so you don't politically liberalize a
communist system unless you want to
commit suicide this is the argument that
i made in armageddon averted and it is
the motto of xi jinping's life
so when many people were saying
oh yeah
if they just liberalize economically and
we integrate them into the global
economy
because of modernization theory they
will have to eventually liberalize
politically because they'll grow a
middle class and the middle class will
demand property rights and the middle
class will want rule of law
and because that's how it always happens
when you have economic growth and
integration into the global economy
being a little dismissive everybody fell
for that including me but a communist
system can't do that
and if it does do that it's bye-bye
and so
people who toy
with political liberalization under
communism those are our friends
we wanted a chinese gorbachev
we didn't get it
because the system selected
as it were for the person who would
preserve the system
who would never permit
the kind of political liberalization
that would end up with a hungary in 56
the czechoslovakian 68 or gorbachev
remember mikhail souzloff
when the scientist he was the
number two in the brezhnev regime the
top ideologue and the scientists went to
him this is before gorbachev and said
we need to liberalize we need to open up
we need to have less censorship and
suslav said
okay we'll do that but who'll send the
tanks to moscow
and so xi jinping as i said is a student
of this process and he's made the whole
regime study this process there is a
pirated edition in chinese
outside of copyright of my work
armageddon averted
about this and i've had discussions in
china and so think about one more
dimension to this
you liberalize
economically
with the communist party monopoly in
place
and you think you can go pretty far
right but then people begin to amass
wealth
they begin to amass independent power
because of their wealth and they begin
to say things like well the border
should be open and the internet should
be open and
and you can only imagine how far that
goes
and so when you liberalize economically
there are limits to that as well
because it's a threat to the communist
monopoly to have independent sources of
power
created by markets and entrepreneurs and
so we're seeing
the crackdown on the private sector
by the communist party
because it threatens their monopoly
the perception is under marxists
that
politics is only the superstructure
right and underneath is the so-called
base or the mode of production the
socioeconomic relations
well the socioeconomic relations if
they're determinative
and they're capitalist
what's going to happen to the leninist
political structures the superstructures
they're not going to survive in the
marxist thinking
and it turns out in reality
not just in marxist thinking but in
reality
opening up your economy and allowing
legal private markets is a threat to the
party's rule so now they're reinserting
communist party officials and communist
party committees into private sector
companies
and so you have a ceo and a board and
then you have a party machine
that's saying this has to align with the
mission of the party meaning it can't
threaten
the party's monopoly okay one more
question on china
well let me set it up there's a
quotation from xi jinping that's being
has been made a lot of over the last
couple of years although it dates from
2013
he gives a behind closed doors speech to
new members of the central committee
and then the speeches of course we have
no idea what he said behind closed doors
but the speech appears
in one of the party's most important
journals
and here's what xi jinping says
in 2013 there are people who believe
that communism
is an unattainable hope
but facts have repeatedly told us that
marx and engel's analysis is not
outdated
capitalism is bound to die out close
quote
all right
you have just said
this party intends to retain power
but power to what
end
power because
this communism
communist talk is just talk
they're an old-fashioned chinese
imperial regime that wants to reassert
their place at the center of world
affairs
or because
you're finding about the soviets and the
soviet archives they're real they're
true believers they're genuine
communists they believe in a worldwide
revolution that will usher in some form
of the marxist version they want to
retain power to what
end we all
thought they were cynics
that they just vowed the communist
ideology
they want the leninist structures to
stay in place politically
and so therefore they try to legitimate
them also with some
verbiage rhetoric
about communism right
and so we were dismissive
of any possibility that the ideology was
still alive
we they couldn't be
smart people couldn't believe that not
after what happened in the soviet union
not after what happened in the triumph
of markets globally
some of them believe it
not only do some of them believe it
but it's inherent in the system
the most
the largest threat to a communist system
is the ideology
the ideology of communism is dynamic and
it produces people who have what we call
socialism with a human face
fantasies
they think that we can do it better next
time
that it wasn't because of the ideology
it was because of
leaders
vena leaders
stalin made mistakes or mao made
mistakes we'll correct those mistakes
we'll have better leaders
and we'll get to socialism with a human
face or communist reform
that is very destabilizing for the
system because the system produces that
the system produces the reform impulse
from within
it also produces the hardline impulse
the andropovs
right or the xi jinpings which is to say
yes we have
a need for more dynamism in the system
but not at the expense of the monopoly
power we have
and so that tension
between the so-called reformers who are
essentially
wearing suicide vests right that's auto
liquidation if they get to power
versus the hardliners who are correct
but don't have they're correct about the
threat to the political stability
but they don't have a growth mechanism
because the markets
the private sector the gdp growth and
the job creation all comes from
something that they don't really believe
in so this is the core problem of
self-destabilization of communist
regimes
let's give them credit there
they've had a remarkable run
of decades and decades of tremendous
economic growth
lifting people out of poverty
because they liberalized economically
and legally permitted a private sector
which did drive that growth
did create those jobs
and has produced an economic miracle
of global impact we could get into the
details of precisely how that worked and
whether the party deserves the credit
for that or somebody else might have
done that
but the impact is there
however
the idea now is
let's redistribute that income
let's get back to where we were before
let's get state control over the economy
state-owned enterprises
where we have greater central party
control than we do of the private sector
you can insert communist parties into
the private sector but you still have
private owners
whereas state-owned enterprises
are much easier for them to control
but then you don't get the gdp growth
then you don't get the dynamism the job
growth
there are other reasons why their growth
is slowing
politics
communist monopoly is not the sole
reason
but it what it is the reason everyone
ignored
because we thought that quotes like that
one that you read from 2013
were cynicism but they're not cynicism
and they are a vulnerability a
self-created vulnerability of the system
question two
the same question i asked about the
president of china applied now to the
president of russia
what does vladimir putin
believe
and what does he want
we all would like to know the answer to
that question peter
we don't get a chance to ask him
personally
i wish that i was sitting
behind the camera and he was sitting in
this chair
and the best interviewer on the west
coast
was sitting across from him like is
sitting across from me right now
and would ask him those questions and
then we would hear it we've had a couple
of very revealing interviews with people
including oliver stones
which allowed putin to speak and putin
has made some dramatic public
interventions beginning with that munich
speech that infamous speech in 2007 at
the
munich security conference
so we have a sense
of what he thinks
but of course he keeps us guessing
and he may not know
so this is going to be
a supposition
i'm going to give a i'm going to go a
little bit around and sideways back in
rather than frontal on this one if
you'll permit
stephen i'll just watch
you're the best show in town
it's very kind of you
so um
when
this russian empire collapsed
in the first world war
and there was the russian revolution
people assumed that that was it
russia was gone
the hopsborg empire austria-hungary
collapsed and it didn't come back
the ottoman empire collapsed and it
didn't come back and the russian empire
collapsed along with the monarchy it
dissolved
and people thought it's a goner it's
finished
but it did come back
and it came back
pretty quickly
within a generation
it was once again an industrializing
powerful country that you couldn't
ignore in the international system
but the entire versailles treaty
which was about punishing germany alone
for the war and excluding the soviet
union
entirely from the versailles
accord
and so russia
wanted to revise
the versailles settlement the world war
one settlement it was imposed on them
they didn't like the world order that
came out of world war one remember
germany won the war on the eastern front
in march 1918 there was the treaty of
brestletops yes germany lost the war on
the western front
which invalidated the treaty of
breslautovsk and made germany a loser on
both sides
but russia was excluded and its
territory had diminished
independent poland came back into
existence
lithuania latvia and estonia became
independent states
part of
the russian empire that is today ukraine
went into independent poland
so russia retreated farther from europe
and was excluded from the settlement
they didn't like the settlement
at first they couldn't do anything about
it
but over time they acquired the
wherewithal
let's call that the tanks and the
airplanes and the trained engineers and
the trained officers
they acquired the wherewithal
to act on their desire to revise
the versailles settlement we know how
well that worked out right
fast forward to 1991
a settlement is imposed the soviet union
dissolves
the united states pronounces itself
properly so the victor
we stood up to that
regime
through thick and thin over various
generations including republican and
democrat both
it was the right thing to do
there were mistakes on our side but the
cold war was right and necessary and
it had a colossal role
in
putting pressure on that system
producing a reformer a socialist with a
human face ideologue
who liquidated that system
unintentionally while trying to insert
dynamism again to face the west
the settlement is imposed the west
expanded
the eu expanded nato expanded and
the territory of russia had been
diminished even more after 1991 than
after 1918.
they had no
possibility to revise that settlement
that they didn't like
boris yeltsin would make speeches about
how this was no good
and we don't like this
like that
the big bear that he was
and so what
bill clinton would just push nato
farther along
george bush would push nato farther
along and there we are today
but lo and behold
russian power came back
something that people assumed
would not happen or if it did happen it
would come back in democratic fashion
because they would have markets and
private property they would grow a
middle class they would be integrated
into the world economy and pygmalion
style we would remake them
into a small junior partner of the
united states and the west
and so of course that didn't work
because they have a sense of themselves
as a special nation with a special
mission in the world a providential
power and they reacquired the
wherewithal
to do something about the settlement
that was imposed by us the victors that
they didn't like
and so they can now do something
the same way
that the post
world war one soviet union acquired that
wherewithal to revise the settlement and
that's what's going on
has been going on for some time and is
going on today so that's what he's about
he's about revising the settlement so he
issues public treaties
they
published the treaties that he wants
with the u.s and nato
calling for a rollback
of the settlement
that has been enacted since 1991
and if they don't get it
they may do it themselves militarily so
that's the situation that we're in
which was foreseeable
because it happened before
it happened before under a different
kind of regime the putin regime is not
the stalin regime right the stalin
category is a small category it includes
mao and hitler putin is not in that
category but nonetheless you see the
phenomenon and so for us
it's understanding that mentality
understanding as well the
vulnerabilities
and understanding
that
we're america and we can
have diplomats again
we can have diplomacy again
so we can go on the offensive
diplomatically so
one more we've only got through two of
my five questions but one follow-up on
this one
xi jinping
and the chinese communist party
are communists you just you said a
moment ago some of them really believe
it
and so there's
among those who believe it they have
expansionist
aims communism says this is the ultimate
end for all mankind not just china all
mankind
and vladimir putin is a russian yes he's
not a communist he's a russian he stands
in a tradition of a thousand years of
trying to assert dominance over that
huge eurasian land mass
so why don't we let him have it
what is our interest
in
in the donbass region of ukraine why
should we even have been
concerned when he recaptured
a next i think is the technical term
when he annexed crimea sebastopol
the russian port on the black sea was
i looked it up the other day it was
established in 1783 by catherine the
great yes it's a russian holding yes let
him expand because that's all he's
interested in he just wants to be
russian and we can live with that
xi jinping is also a chinese nationalist
it's just that he inherited a communist
regime and had a communist upbringing
but he's trying to preserve the power of
that regime but also promote chinese
nationalism
putin has a personal regime
it's not fully institutionalized
we're not sure
how it works because it's got narrower
and narrower and narrower at the top the
inner circle is smaller than ever and we
don't really have access interlocutors
with those people
as we did previously when the regime was
a little bit less narrow and the second
echelon participated in discussions
about policy and we had access to them
and the first echelon was wider
so we're not sure
this is what we know for sure though
what we know is they're afraid
they're afraid of their own people
and they're afraid of american power
they're more afraid of american power
than we are proud of american power
we think democracy promotion
is how we lead well at least some of us
think that
in fact it's just the very existence of
our system that threatens both the
russian regime and the chinese regime
today
we are an example
of how
freedom operates in practice imperfectly
with all sorts of the chaos and
cacophony that we know
is america as well as other democracies
and that's ipso facto a threat to them
hong kong
was a threat
taiwan
is a threat the united states by its
very existence is a threat to them
because it's a different kind of system
that could interest their people right
and so
we don't have to promote democracy and
we're still threatening them every day
so how do they respond
to our threat
because we exist
and the way they respond to it is
they want to divide
they want to divide our alliances they
want to divide our country
they want to weaken us so that we don't
understand
that we are more powerful
that we have a better military a better
financial system
that we have corrective mechanisms in
our political system that we have deep
and dynamic markets
and that no matter what goes wrong in a
private economy there are corrective
mechanisms to create new jobs and to
pull us out of slums we have what they
don't have
we have just a tremendous can't be
bottled
american power across all dimensions and
self-correcting mechanisms we forget
but that's who we are and what we have
and they know that and so for them
they must counteract that
we have alliance systems they must
divide them
we have rule of law
they must have propaganda saying that
our rule of law doesn't work
that it's unfair
that
it's corrupt or whatever it might be and
fill in the blank
i don't mind that they do that it
doesn't frighten me i'm not frightened
by them
i expect them to do that
what i don't like and what scares me a
little bit is when we do that to
ourselves
when we denigrate our institutions
when we say that we're a terrible system
when we say that american power
is imperialist
when we say things that the communist
chinese and the russian nationalists say
about ourselves and we bash ourselves
now we have freedom here
and people are allowed to say things
like that and we have a lot of
institutions and a lot of trends which
need correction and can be improved
and fortunately we're allowed to discuss
that freely in the public realm
but at the same time let's not forget
who we are
where we came from what our strengths
are nobody in russia or china
can destroy america only people in
america can do that all right
i'll return to that in a moment question
three
war now i'm going to take a moment or
two to set this one up
it's something i've been thinking about
in these couple of years since we've
seen each other
but here's the way i'll do it
just a few years before he died in 2015
renee girard
literary critic
political thinker
anthropologist
my neighbor as it happens we lived
across the street from each other so i
got to know renee quite well all right
renee girard publishes a book just
before he dies
called battling to the end
which is an interview with him
by a journalist
on his reading
of klausevitz
klausevitz publishes actually it's
published after he dies but he publishes
1830 a book on war
which he wrote after he himself had
witnessed
the napoleon and participated in the
napoleonic wars
all right
so
as i say i'm going to take a moment to
set this up and then just let you have
it
rene gerard
toward the end of his life reads klaus
of its for the first time and he notices
that klaus of its immediately grasps an
internal dynamic
and now we quote clausewitz if one side
uses force without compunction
that side will force the other to follow
suit even the most civilized of peoples
can be fired with passionate hatred of
each other
the thesis must be repeated
war is an act of force
and there is no
logical limit
to the application of that force close
quote all right
then rene gerard notes the klausovitz
stansbe
he bridges two worlds of war
he appears as the old 18th century model
gentleman's wars let's say
wars of maneuver relatively minor
casualties that dominates europe
is fading
and he witnesses
this vast escalation of war that occurs
under napoleon
when napoleon
mobilizes for the first time we see well
perhaps a till of the hun but that's a
separate matter but for the first time
in modern history we see
this notion of national mobilization the
french do it first and they sweep across
europe
and
renee gerard has this phrase that he
refers to the acceleration of history
limited
combat in gentleman's wars an entirely
new and far more destructive kind of
warfare under napoleon
and of course you see where this is
going
the chinese have developed hypersonic
missiles
vladimir putin still has some 5 000
nuclear
weapons
all right
renee gerard insists
human nature hasn't changed
and neither has the internal dynamic of
war to repeat that phrase again there is
no logical limit to the application of
force
against all that this is robinson here
against all that we have 45 years of the
cold war
when the nuclear weapons in some
paradoxical way limited combat all over
again
so
johnson won't invade lyndon johnson
won't invade china because he doesn't
want to risk a nuclear war so he limits
himself limited objections
even richard nixon only mines haifang
harbor
limited bombing even of hanoi a bigger
pardon hanoi harbor
so we have these two different visions
renee sees
who knows where the mistake might occur
but if there's another war we could be
facing armageddon
and against that we have the actual
experience of a half a century of
superpower conflict between us and the
soviets
which in some ways was encouraging the
conflict is limited
i've even heard the argument
and i don't know the history well enough
to judge it but i've even heard the
argument that even between india and
pakistan
the moment both get
acquire nuclear powers they're much more
careful of each other
all right
so
has technology
does take
nuclear weapons and whatever comes next
of nuclear weapons in space whatever
comes next we know technology will
continue we have this acceleration of
history that's going to continue
should be should we be very
very concerned or should we say no
oddly enough the technology tends to
limit the violence
peter this is a great subject thank you
for bringing it up
it's true
that
deterrence operates
as long as it operates
human beings can launch a nuclear war
and so yes
most human beings
would not want to have mutual
destruction
otherwise known as mad mutually assured
destruction
that therefore prohibited a big war
because if i started i get annihilated
and the answer is that seems really
logical and really helpful to prevent it
until someone decides
okay
i'll destroy you you'll destroy me
that's just the way it's going to go
in other words
there's the deterrent as long as
individuals in positions of authority to
launch the nuclear war
feel that deterrent
but the moment they don't
that deterrent is no longer operative
which is why george schultz
spent
a lifetime actually it was three
lifetimes
first because of the length of time
george lived but also because of the
level of activity
dynamism and productivity he had
because if you still have the capability
it could be used
let's talk a little bit about war
in addition to the way you framed it
vladimir putin is not hitler
and cannot be put in the same sentence
with hitler
but let me make a little bit of a
comparison so people can understand
ukraine now
hitler went to munich
and he wanted a war
and he got talked into going to munich
and he got the sudetenland for free
and he got the skoda works
in the sudetenland western
czechoslovakia without having to pay
compensation was probably the best
military factory in europe in 1938 this
is the munich agreement where neville
chamberlain returns home and waves a
piece of paper and says chancellor
hitler and i have achieved peace in our
time hitler got everything he wanted for
nothing right
but he didn't get the war which is what
he wanted more than anything else and he
was angry and disappointed about munich
having achieved a total victory in klaus
fitzsense
without having to fight
win the war without fighting right sun
tzu
the greatest chinese theorist of war
said the best war of all is the one you
win without fighting which is what
hitler did at munich
putin is the opposite
he wants his demands met
without having to fight the war in
ukraine
we can live with a man like that it's
easier if you understand
that he's constrained
by the fact that russian public opinion
is not in favor of invading ukraine
and that ukrainian public opinion is not
in favor of being annexed by russia
so he needs our concessions
without him launching the war
he needs from us
what hitler got at munich
at the same time if he has to
go farther he won't go immediately to
invasion
he will ratchet the pressure up
until he gets the concessions
so let's take an example of what he
could do
i have no
access to secret information from our
government
i do not have classified information
whatsoever
this is purely me thinking
there's a government in kiev what if
kiev becomes unlivable
what if for example the water supply is
poisoned or the air is poisoned somehow
i don't know who did that right
and suddenly it's unlivable city and the
government evacuates along with refugees
the populace
and they go to lavif
in western ukraine and set up a
temporary government there
while they're seeing what's going to
happen to kiev and so they've
self-evacuated kiev and putin is denying
that he had anything to do with the fact
that the water supply was poisoned and
the air is poisoned how did that happen
and all of a sudden
there's an uprising in harkov
and it declares itself a pro-russian
ukrainian regime
harkov was the original capital of
soviet ukraine
and so you have
a different ukrainian government and
harkov
an unlivable capital kiev
and a ukrainian government in lavif
which is the former part of the ukraine
that's formerly part of poland and
before that austria-hungary
and so you've dismembered the country
without invading
and so you can ratchet up you start with
cyber
and you show your teeth that way
and then you say can we have these
concessions
and that doesn't work but you can
escalate short of
full-scale war and invasion
because
you
your people don't want a war
they don't want an invasion
and so you're constrained even though
you won't admit it and we don't think
about that in russia
but he has these escalation mechanisms
covert ops type escalation mechanisms
are we ready for that or not
i don't know once again because i don't
have access
to the classified discussions
but in thinking the scenarios through
his ability to ratchet up the pressure
and make demands
is something we need to pay attention to
he's not going to be angry like hitler
was if we make concessions to him and he
doesn't have the war
so you don't put yourself in a position
where you haven't negotiated a
settlement with him
where he's angry
and can
use wherewithal that he's built up and
acquired in the time since 1991
to cause this kind of tension
and we don't have a diplomatic process
prior to this
and now we're scrambling to get a
diplomatic process right the way
diplomacy works peter and someone who
was in the reagan administration doesn't
need me to explain this
is you build yourself up
you get yourself ready
and then you prompt diplomatic
negotiations from a position of strength
you initiate the diplomacy right you are
on the front foot you're on the
you have a diplomatic offensive
you don't sit there wait reactively and
say we're pivoting to china we're
pivoting to asia we're getting out of
the middle east and the russia thing god
forbid anything should happen
well that's where we are right now and
that's where we have been under more
than one administration and so this is
war one final point if i could on war
war is not what we think it is anymore
war is not i shoot artillery you shoot
artillery i shoot a missile you shoot a
missile
war is about
doing things
like making cities unlivable and forcing
millions of refugees to flee
it's about shutting down communication
systems transportation systems right
it's about shutting the lights off and
shutting the power off blowing things up
and saying i didn't do that it's about
decapitating the leadership
war is about
eliminating
the other society's ability to function
not just the battlefield it's the
society that's the aim and so in a war
game you don't invade
you turn a country off
you make a country unlivable
turn the country off
and so that's where we are with war
and so god forbid peter
there hasn't been a war that wasn't a
tragedy
there have been wars that were necessary
but all wars have been tragic world war
ii was 55 million approximately
civilians as well as soldiers on the
battlefield what would world war three
look like
i i don't even want to think about that
and therefore i need a diplomatic
offensive
i need george schultz like authoritative
figures
i need a president who understands
that you have to have more lethality
than they do
and they have to know that
and that goes across the board but you
also need a public behind you
you see because putin's weaker because
the russian
they don't want a war in ukraine and so
if our president is going to do
something the public has to understand
and they have to be behind him
that brings us to question four
a house divided
our house yes
and again
i'll take a moment here to set it up
in a recent lecture on history you said
this
and this is yesterday and i was taking
notes
countries that are defeated by their
enemies often rebuild
but the countries that are destroyed
from within
that's really the end of the line
all right
so again let me take a moment to set
this up ross dow that in the new york
times earlier this very week
dow that writes
the country is more ideologically
polarized than it was 20 or 40 years ago
we're more likely to hate and fear
members of the rival party more likely
to sort ourselves into ideologically
homogeneous communities more likely to
be skeptical about our own public
institutions
more likely to hold conspiratorial
beliefs
how civil wars start is a new book by a
prominent political scientist
and and ross dow that writes that was
cited all over the place
in the days around the anniversary of
last winter's riot at the capitol close
quote
polarization even talk
of civil war
slowing economic growth over
the last couple of decades i think most
economists would argue
declining
marriage rates declining fertility rates
last year for the first time in the
history of this republic
the population of the united states
shrank
so the question is this
i think back to this recent history that
you just mentioned
1970s in this country
we have economic stagnation
collapse of national morale with
watergate and the defeat in vietnam
we have an erosion of our position in
the cold war
as the soviets expand
africa latin america
and then the very next decade
we have economic growth
a restoration of national morale
and victory in the cold war from 1979 to
1989 10 years
we go from the national humiliation of
the hostage crisis in iran
to victory in the cold war with the fall
of the berlin wall
how bad is it now
and is this country capable
of another act
another great act
of self-renewal
let's admit peter that that is the
question
and let's also admit that i'm not an
expert on the united states i'm only a
taxpayer
in fact i pay taxes in new jersey
because i work at princeton university i
pay taxes in new york city in new york
state because i live in manhattan i pay
taxes in massachusetts because my wife
works at harvard and i pay taxes in
california
because i'm an adjunct senior fellow at
the hoover institution i have not
figured out how to pay taxes in illinois
yet
but obviously i have to check that box
too to get every single uh
yes
so i'm only a taxpayer
and you can see that i'm not very clever
because i'm managing to pay taxes in all
the worst jurisdictions for that this is
my take on that we're not polarized
peter
in the sense that polarization is a
problem
this is a big and diverse nation
there are 330 million people
and we run the gamut from far left to
far right and everything in between
and there are crazies and there are
people who think other people are crazy
and vice versa and we're america and
that's okay and we've always been like
that
it would be kind of bizarre
if we didn't have
a great diversity of opinion in our
country
it would be weird it would be
inexplicable
if
in fact
there was no intellectual diversity
across
no political diversity across our
country the way there is at our great
liberal universities right now it would
be bizarre
the problem is not polarization
i was
at the university of california berkeley
in a phd program when ronald reagan was
president
so nobody's going to tell me that
there's some type of political craziness
now
that's greater than what there was back
then
the problem is demonization
not polarization
the problem is
two people disagree
and they're evil for disagreeing they're
beyond the pale and if they get back
into power the republic is over
and so everything becomes existential in
a demonization
situation
so if if those guys get in it's the end
of our republic
and if those guys get in it's the end of
our republic when something is
existential you have to fight to the
death
and you have to use any means necessary
including breaking all norms
breaking your institutions because it's
existential it's the end of the republic
that demonization
empirically it's not the end of the
republic
i'll remind your
fantastic audience
that donald trump was president
and we're living in the american
republic today
i'll remind your fantastic audience that
joe biden is president today and at some
point will not be president again
and we will still be living in the
american republic
so the existentialism is a lie and it's
a mutually reinforcing lie
and it needs to be broken
the demonization is the problem
it comes from
all sorts of good ideas that have had
perverse and unintended consequences
let's make
who gets to be a candidate more
democratic
instead of a smoke-filled room
let's have a primary
and let's have only people of that party
vote
for their candidates not cross-party
primaries
and so
a small percentage of one party shows up
because they're the ones who go to vote
in a primary and they're a small
percentage of the nation
and they
produce the candidates that the whole
nation then has to adjudicate
and it's
what happened these are our candidates
this is america can't we do better
and so the idea of more democracy
produced the demonization in part
and so we need less democracy
we need smoke-filled rooms again
we don't need these primaries or we need
primaries where everyone can vote no
matter what party they belong to
and pick candidates
who are more aligned with the median
voter
remember our system is designed to
thwart anything but a broad coalition
right
and you can't form a broad coalition
under demonization can you
you can get 50
plus one
and you can ram through
everything you think you need for your
side because it's existential
you can get three supreme court justices
and colossal tax cuts
with the margin being too small to see
without a microscope
and then
the margin shifts
that same too small to see without a
microscope but it shifts the other way
and then you can reinvent all of our
institutions from top to bottom
whether it's federalizing voting
or
some of the other things that are on the
table now right
how silly is that it's silly yes but
it's because of the demonization the
existentialism
the if the other side gets in it's the
end of the world
if the incentives change
the behavior changes
if you're incentivized to appeal in the
primary to the median voter
you get a different candidate
if you're incentivized in the national
if your districts are not gerrymandered
by the democrats for their side and the
republicans for this so there are many
tweaks
of our democracy
that could get us back to
making our system work
being aligned with the median voter
things not being
existential not getting
everything you want with fifty plus one
percent no matter which side you're on
there are people out there who've
diagrammed this pretty well from uval 11
to all the other
ross all the other fantastic people
you've had on your show and programs
that i've watched i'm not an expert as i
said i'm just a taxpayer and an observer
but i understand incentives and i
understand that incentivizes certain
behavior can we renew ourselves of
course we can how do we know we've done
it many times before
many times we did have a civil war
it was over something much deeper than
any issue we have before us today
it was over the crime of slavery
there's no other way to describe it
people in this country were not
considered human beings let alone
citizens
we rectified that
it was very hard
it was very costly and it didn't end
just with the civil war and the work
continues today and the civil rights
movement was a spectacular efflorescence
of all races in all walks of life coming
together
to advance
that agenda of the civil war that was
incomplete
that's within us we know because it was
there we've seen it we study that
history we understand it we have
the ability we just need to
incentivize different types of behavior
and we also need to revive civics
to remind people what institutions we
have
how they work
why they're valuable
and why we are
the nation that we are it's not that
hard
provided you change a few incentives a
few mechanisms a few institutions right
you know this with your kids
if you give them one incentive you
elicit one type of behavior you give and
they're the same good kids that you
raised
it's just you change their incentives a
little
question five last question
patriotism
use when talking about
china and russia
and this country's diplomacy
you're being what
what you are professional you have been
on this during this conversation what
you are professionally which isn't
an analyst a historian who places even
his own country at a certain
professional district distance as he
talks about it
just now in this last question about the
country you're talking about
the country as a taxpayer but again
you're talking this institution that
institution all right
i happen to know
that you don't feel
a professional distance from this
country
i know you well enough to know that you
love the
country so here's the question
and
if you have an ideal
audience
in mind for addressing this question i
suggest it's not me
it's not even the ordinary listener
it's the kids
you've spent three decades now teaching
undergraduates at princeton
all right
so for an under here is the question
it's the last question
and i'd like to to address it to kids in
their late teens and early twenties who
are trying to figure this out
to stephen cotkin this remarkable
accomplished figure who is a brilliant
analyst
does he love his country for the same
reason he loved his mother
good and understandable reasons but
essentially subjective reasons
or are there rational grounds
for loving
this country for loving this country
in particular
yes
and i'm not afraid to admit it and to
talk about it at length if we had such
length
this country's given me
everything i was not born into what i
have today
but i was given every opportunity to
succeed
and when i did succeed i was rewarded
and that had a lot to do
not just with the hard work
with the good upbringing i had thanks to
my parents
it had a lot to do with the morays
as well as the institutions of this
country
i was able
to work hard at school
and to continue in school until i didn't
want to go to school anymore
and then compete for a position
and then work hard and succeed
and yes the country that this country
gave that to me
my parents gave a lot to me yes and the
country gave a lot to me and i'm here
today because of that i didn't come up
from
a different country i came up from this
country and young people deserve that
opportunity
i live on west end avenue right now
and two blocks over from me
at least it's
you could say it's a block and a half
our housing projects
and my kids were born on west end avenue
in our house
and those kids were born in those
housing projects
why no explanation they didn't choose
that
they need
every opportunity to be able to succeed
they need school systems that are
excellent with excellent teachers we
have such school systems in new york
in the public system and my kids went
there
and you know what
my kid went to one of the best high
schools in this country
stuyvesant high school a stem school in
new york city
you have to test to get in there
and half the kids in there on subsidized
lunches
what does that tell you
it tells you that they're not all west
end avenue kids who got in there who
were able to pass the test
there are a hundred different hundred
plus different nationalities in that
school
with languages in the corridor running
from syrian to afghani to korean to
chinese
it's remarkably diverse remarkably
accomplished school and it's a public
school
and it's in new york city and we need
more schools like that peter
we need a lot more schools and they
should be in the neighborhoods where
those kids don't have the same
opportunity that my kids had it's about
equality of opportunity
not equality of outcome
equality of outcome delivers perverse
and unintended consequences you want to
make everybody equal well
i'll
show you some history books i wrote
about how that turns out the best
intentions perverse and unintended
consequences but when you give equality
of opportunity including on the front
end
not admission to stanford
when it's too late for the intellectual
capital and the social capital and the
human capital and everything else that
these kids deserve
you got to start on the front end
and so i'm in favor of investing
in education and our kids
paying our teachers
like they were lawyers or doctors
and paying them a differentiated wage if
they're better than the others
the way that private schools do
i'm in favor of opportunity and we
should have an opportunity agenda
there should be a party in this country
called the american opportunity party
and it should be all about those kids
not just my kids my kids
have every opportunity because of what i
could provide not only what the country
could provide but i didn't have that
when i was growing up so i know
and so i love this country for that
reason alone but also many other reasons
dr stephen cotkin
historian
taxpayer
and patriot
thank you stephen
good to have you back thank you for
uncommon knowledge the hoover
institution and fox nation
i'm peter robinson
[Music]
you